hey guys so if you haven't noticed over
the past couple weeks there has been a
piece of jewelry on my ring finger this
is the thing that made Frodo go to the
mountain oh that's a girl so completely
bonkers yes I got engaged about two
weeks ago to my boyfriend partner I like
to say guy I do some [ __ ] with when
people ask what why we do some [ __ ]
together you know I mean who's also his
name is David oh yeah which people kid
they think it's just incredible oh you
the Dave squared the Dave squared we get
the David's is like the David says yeah
I like that so I did I got engaged okay
wait yes he didn't just get engaged okay
are you allowed to tell the story of how
it happened yeah okay
very romantic all right very romantic
so Dave took his boyfriend David to one
of his favorite bands concerts Fleetwood
Mac at perform which I was very jealous
when I saw on Twitter hey Mac and I'm
like how did I not get Fleetwood Mac
tickets at the forum wait anyway wait
the play thing is though that we had
just gone with Kelly Dave and I had just
gone with Kelly to journey like a month
and a half of yes so you are someone
that I would call to go to concerts like
I moved out yeah and you and then I
wanted to respond like I can't anything
he couldn't respond I was afraid if I
even texted you to say well I'm asking
him tonight right he was gonna accident
right my phone so then I just ignored
you which you must have been in commute
it was okay I wept in the corner but it
was finer than that yeah so then so you
took him to this concert which is this
is one of his favorite bands and then
during the band's a song that he loves
his favorites his favorite song okay and
thank God they played it dream his
favorite song thank God that was fun
thing was I wasn't worried about asking
like I knew he was gonna say yes I was
completed that all that stuff was fine
right that was my one worry that like I
had checked the second oldest woman
would not react the same well you know
what's funny word but I also realized
about feedback is for all that you know
they have 25 great songs everybody else
but all their love songs are really pain
yeah yeah I'm not like typical under 70
I love songs yeah yeah yeah it's a
a lot of ripping things apart and that's
it's really it's a perfect analogy for
what happened to the band everything
right but I had checked a playlist a
night before they did play dreams third
and then in a beautiful sign and I know
you like signs on the way when we were
about a block away from the forum the
song dreams came on the radio nice
so like that that's when I was like the
University yeah the universe is talking
awesome so yes I am getting married we
will see when it happens but obviously
natural said yes he said yes and all
that good stuff did you just say no I
mean dream sleep would Mack the whole
thing pretty good you get him down on
your knee or something I didn't get down
on my knee but the people behind us you
know Fleetwood Mac excuse a little bit
older in the audience yes and the people
behind us they were probably in there
like mid I don't know mid 60s or early
70s maybe they were very excited that a
gay couple was getting engaged right
like they done this is the coolest thing
they have ever seen it's very cool which
also shows such a sign of the times that
like gays getting married is now cool
yeah I mean why yes and I just can't
wait actually for five more years to
pass when gays can think about marriage
the same way straight people do which is
like another marriage like that's all we
want like that's what equality is yes
like I'd be miserable to be equally
miserable we want ultimately is the
truth you know so yeah and and we'll see
so we're trying to figure out all the
details there's a chance that you're
number one right now on the list of
who's gonna do this so comment below if
you I know is your officiate the
government have you done a gay wedding
before you die I have not done a gay
wedding but I've done about 15 weddings
now I'm really good that will not be a
dry eye in the house I got I miss you
cuz you can do the good stuff you can do
sappy and real but also funny and funny
real sappy spiritual down-to-earth
whatever you want the whole thing all of
it alright well so there you go I'm
getting married
Kelly is happily married you were just
in Hawaii with your husband and yeah an
edgy job it'll be 20 years this 2015 for
Bob and I my husband and I 20 years
we've been married huh well David and I
have been together for four years which
engagers is actually 30 there you go
anyways married do you think I should
get married what stupid question or any
of that stuff comment down below
subscribe blah blah blah